this next story is just a funny one
about the highly trigger able nature of
Donald Trump we've already done all the
serious stuff related to impeachment
when will the trial be what happened
what were the votes what are the
articles all that stuff uh you know how
Trump always wants to be the best at
everything the most this the best that
he has the biggest thing or whatever you
know Trump was impeached with more votes
against him than any previous president
and this is particularly notable since
there are numerous vacancies in the
House of Representatives right now we
already talked about the big picture
Trump is only the third president to be
impeached Trump has been impeached by
the most overwhelming vote margin in the
house of any other president which is
hilarious now I want to be very clear
the house was smaller
when Andrew Johnson was impeached so by
percentage a higher proportion voted to
impeach Andrew Johnson than Trump but in
terms of sheer numbers Clinton got no
more than 228 votes to impeach on either
article Andrew Johnson had 126 in favor
the house was smaller then and Donald
Trump on the other hand had 230 and 229
in favor of the impeachment Trump is the
most impeached president in history
again not the highest portion but the
highest number and of course Trump
tweeting this morning in all caps
once again the refrain presidential
harassment remember that back in 2014
when Barack Obama was president Donald
Trump said he called into Fox News and
he said listen aside from a conviction
merely being impeached for a president
turns you into a mess Obama would be a
mess under impeachment Obama would be
thinking of nothing other than
impeachment this is Trump talking about
this back in 2004 or what your 2014
sorry take a look do you think Obama
seriously wants to be impeached and go
through what what Bill Clinton did he
would be a mess he would be thinking
about nothing but it would be a horror
show for him it would be an absolute
embarrassment it would go down on his
record permanently but this thing Oh
he'd love to be impeached that would be
so good and the Republicans are also
though would never a Featured would
never beat him because he
like that well and the Republicans I'm a
Republican is a Republican we have to
assume that this is likewise a horror
show for Donald Trump an embarrassment
for Donald Trump on trump's permanent
record as he said it would be on Barack
Obama's but back to this story this is
why it matters I get it Trump was
impeached with the largest number of
votes but it was just over 50% of the
votes compared to the overwhelming
percentage that voted to impeach Andrew
Johnson this is a reminder about the
importance of voting in the midterms
every vote for impeachment last night
was an election that was fought and won
in the midterms right dozens or more
volunteers and staffers were involved in
each of those congressional elections in
the midterms of 2018 each vote is a
congressional district that Democrats
won in 2018 this should remind us how
directly our effort during midterms
translates into real things in the real
world so if you volunteered on a
campaign in 2018 and that candidate won
you volunteered and caused there to be
two hundred and thirty votes to impeach
instead of two twenty nine or two twenty
nine instead of two twenty eight
depending on the article this stuff has
real-world impact and we need to always
remember this
especially in non presidential election
years in midterm years where turnout is
often lower engagement also tends to be
much lower every single one of those
campaigns represents one impeachment
vote they are up for re-election every
two years in the House of
Representatives they're up again right
now and there is no greater reminder of
the importance of this and by the way
what's going on with judges is another
reminder but we'll talk about that right
after this next short break